um you know you hear very frequently
people say things like everyone's
creative it's like that's wrong okay
it's wrong it's just as wrong as saying
that everyone's extroverted first of all
you have to be pretty damn smart to be
creative because otherwise you're just
going to get to where other people have
already got and that's not creative by
definition so so being fast and being
out there at the front of things really
makes a difference and then you also
have to have these divergent thinking
capabilities and that's part of your
trait structure and creative people are
really different than non creative
people you know partly because for
example they're highly motivated to do
creative things and to experience
novelty in - and - and to chase down
aesthetic experiences in to attend
movies and to read fiction and to go to
museums and to enjoy poetry and and and
to enjoy music that's not conventional
music for example
these aren't trivial differences and so
and so it's a real it's a real missed
statement to make the proposition that
everyone's created it's just simply not
the case it's a matter of wishful
thinking it's like saying that everyone
is intelligent like well if everyone is
intelligent and then the term loses all
of its meaning because any term that you
can apply to every member of a category
I have absolutely no meaning now that
doesn't and you know the other thing you
want to be thinking about here is it
don't be thinking that creativity is
such a good thing it's a high-risk
high-return strategy so if you're
creative you just tried it there's
creative people in this room man you
guys are going to have a hell of a time
monetizing your creativity it's
virtually impossible it's really really
difficult because first of all let's say
you make an original product you think
the world will be the pathway to your
door if you build a better mousetrap
it's like that's complete rubbish it
isn't even true in the least if you make
a good creative product you've probably
solved about 5% of your problem because
then you have marketing which is
insanely difficult and then you have
sales and then you have customer support
and then you have to build an
organization and you have to it is
really novel you have to tell people
what the hell the thing is you know we
built this future authoring program or
anything like it so it's available for
people online how do you market that no
one knows what that is and that's a real
problem if you wrote a book well then
you have the problem that another
million people have also written a book
but if you produce something that's
completely new and
and have a category people can't search
for it online how are they going to find
it
so you just have and then you have
pricing problems and it's really
unbelievably difficult to produce
something creative and then monetize it
and even worse if you're the creative
person let's say you have a spectacular
invention you've got no money right
you've got no customer
there's no they're big problems and so
maybe you go and you find a venture
capitalist we start with family and
friends because that's how it works you
raise money for your product you raise
money from your family and friends
that's assuming you have family and
friends that have some money and that
they're going to give it to you and most
people aren't in that situation so it's
a terrible barrier right off the bat and
then of course you're putting your
family and friends at substantial
financial risk because the probability
that your stupid idea is going to make
money is virtually zero even if it's a
really brilliant idea and so then let's
say well you get past family and friends
and you get venture capital capitalists
involved because that's often the next
step or an angel investor that's there's
their steps in building a business
family and friends angel investor that's
some rich guy that you happen to meet
some manner in some way who's who's into
this sort of thing and is willing to
provide you with some money to get your
product off the ground well how much of
your product is that person going to
take well most of it most of it and then
if you get a venture and no wonder
because you know you don't have any
money
how are you going a bargain for control
over your product he'll just say well do
you want the money or not and if your
answer is no then he'll go and do
something else with his money it's not
like there's no shortage of things that
you can do with your money because
there's a million things you can do with
it so you're not in a great bargaining
position and then if you get venture
capitalists involved they'll take
another big chunk and maybe if they're
not very straight with you they'll just
throw you out because maybe by that
point in the company's development
you're nothing but a pain in the neck
because what do you know about marketing
and sales and customer service and
building an organization and running a
business like you don't have a clue so
why do they need you so even if you're
successful at generating a new idea and
you put it into a business the
probability that you as the originator
of the of the idea are going to make
some money from it is very very low so
don't be thinking that creativity is
such a it's such a sum
you would want to curse yourself with
now you know it's not all bad because it
opens up avenues of experience for
creative people that aren't available to
people who aren't creative but it
definitely is a high-risk high-return
strategy you know so the overwhelming
probability is that you will fail but a
small proportion of creative people
succeed spectacularly and so it's like a
lottery in some sense you're probably
going to lose but if you don't lose you
could win big and that keeps a lot of
creative people going but also they
don't really have much choice in it
because if you're a creative person
you're like a fruit tree that's that's
bearing fruit so you don't really have
you can suppress it but it's very bad
for you
you know the creative people I've worked
with is if they're not creative they're
miserable so they have to do it but and
you know there's real joy and pleasure
in it and and the end and end and
psychological utility but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's an
intelligent it's certainly not a
conservative strategy for moving forward
through life so and you know whenever I
talk to people who are creative and you
guys should listen to this because I
know what I'm talking about if you
happen to be creative if you're a
songwriter or another kind of musician
or an artist or or any of the other
number of things that you might be find
a way to make money and then practice
your craft on the side because you'll
starve to death otherwise now some for
some of you that won't be true but it's
a tiny minority your best bet is to find
a job that will keep body and soul
together and parse off some time that
you can pursue your creative thing
because then well as a long term
strategy you medium to long term
strategy it's a better one but it's got
incredibly difficult for people
musicians for example it's incredibly
difficult for new musicians to monetize
their their craft even if they're really
really good at it so it's it's well so
anyways so don't be so I say well
everyone's not everyone's not creative
and everybody goes oh that's terrible
it's like it's not so terrible it's not
something it's not self-evident that you
would curse someone with high levels of
creativity